ja dieser ganzen abend bestand einfach
daraus dass red und ich halte beide
irgendwie so ein bisschen meego sind ja
und jeder zeigen wir bei der größere
macke ist und die entwickler haben alle
möglichen scheiße zu machen versteht und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
ja heute gibt's keine wo es begrüßen
sondern einfach eine ganz normale alte
begrüßung ich habe heute für euch mit
absoluten knaller leute ihr habt ein
viertel schon gesehen ich habe nämlich
ein video mit apa red das ist kein
bullshit und kein krieg baker wo wir
zusammen interagieren wieder zusammen
bei dem video auf und damit wieder autos
zusammenfalten gedreht dieses video gibt
ihnen jetzt auf youtube online und das
scheint heute an das ganze video ist ein
bisschen älter und zwar stammt das auf
2014 hochgeladen wurde ist auf welchem
kanal auf dem kanal von der eiskanal
wurde vor zwei jahren mit video
die video 2014 block aus berlin kamera
geklaut hochgeladen und in diesem video
taufen rats zusammen
ich dachte einfach so jetzt der vater
erneut musikvideo rausgebracht ja ich
werde mich aber der musik video
anschauen was gemeint ist das zu sagen
die greifen das ganze thema häufig in
anders so der ganze spaß viel los am
anfang nicht gesagt gar nicht so viel
auf seite intro von arbeit leute ich
wenigstens firma sowie blauth das kann
man wirklich keinem erzählen etwa dabei
macht der junge macht damals da hat er
noch ein paar kilo weniger draußen
absturz doch erst mal das bin ich da
hinten einer ist ein echtes finden
der anfang an gesehen ich damit auch
ehrlich gesagt haben der ganzen sache
ein bisschen kontext zu geben das war
der sogenannte d-day der haben sich ein
großteil der youtuber die damals bei dem
hof unter vertrag standen in berlin
getroffen bei seiner veranstaltung
handle me zusammen irgendeinen event
gemacht was gekocht bei dem tag war eine
ganze menge youtuber eben auch was mach
ich aber auch alfred und ein paar andere
also max erweitern ich war unterwegs und
erobert und seine ganoven waren auch
unterwegs man hier richtig verrückte
leute würden jetzt meinen betrachtung
wäre damals ein straßenstrich
nachdem wir dann angekommen sind sind
wir am für ein bisschen in berlin
rumgelaufen haben wird appelrath royal
und kollegen getroffen und habe ein paar
wichtige tendenz für mich war dieses
setting her okay leute das ist der
alexanderplatz in berlin-mitte waren sie
gesagt in berlin unterwegs ewig lange
als möglich ewig lang und ihr seht ist
ein bisschen heller den zeitungen gehen
gerade tatsächlich schon die sonne auf
als fünf oder sechs uhr morgens für man
schon den ganzen abend berlin unterwegs
und dann passiert alles klar
ihr seht diese dinge im hintergrund
diese bügel okay was wir gemacht haben
ist sie haben gesagt okay diese bügel da
diese fahrradständer wir machen jetzt
mehr fitness challenge ja und zwar
stetig gegen red an und wir gucken wer
mehr geschafft okay also gibt habe ich
eine biografie auch mal gesagt sind
übung da hat man hier die gestanden
letztere war unterdrückt ich wieder hoch
runter hoch muss sagen retter damals
sich schon selbst finde ich sehr gepusht
und war da auf jeden fall schon der
überzeugung dass er nur ruhe ist auch
damals schon als nicht gehabt ich war
ein bisschen andere meinung hat gemeint
ich stecken in taschen das gesagt komm
jeder weiß was die machen jetzt fitness
battle
sie gehen an diese dinger jeder schnappt
sich zwei und wir gucken wer sich öfter
hochbrücke neben mir sitzt machen kann
und ja
die ansagen
[Musik]
er verpackte macht noch eine art und
damit habe ich dieses battle da für mich
entschieden tatsächlich hat schon
gemerkt die ausführung war damals sehr
sehr bescheiden als wir beide hatten
ungefähr so und oberkörper bewegt die
auswahl wirklich grottenschlecht die
dinger sind aber auch sehr weit
auseinander muss man dazu auf seine
tiere hätten die wehrleute denke ich ist
wahrscheinlich auch what the [ __ ] bieter
sind diese zeitung in einem video ja ich
wäre jetzt videos gemacht hat die
upgrade kann ich kopfrechnen und dürfen
mit weniger lustig gemacht habe ich
damals den effekt des challenge gegen
ihn gemacht und hab dann natürlich auch
gebaut
jetzt also ich pushen 0 in front es gibt
auf feucht am start ist auch gar nicht
viel wichtiger geworden hat aber ich
darf jetzt damit max und luca in köln in
max paket an dieses video auch nicht
erklären kann doch nicht sein man damals
weiß ich einfach dass mahler coldplay
mittlerweile hat er dinge raus gehauen
wie numero uno oder papa wagen und ich
habe einfach mega herumgelaufen richtig
richter häufige wachstum klein vom übel
schilliger abend und naja hintergrund
sehe wie wieder irgendwas oder go kart
warum gelacht
dort ist jetzt noch nächste highlight
dann war auch da auf dem alexanderplatz
morgen von fünfte abgesperrt in brokat
bahn ja da wo eigentlich go kart fahren
hätten aus unseren zaun dann hat mir
natürlich die zwei berufliche
missgeburten in unserer clique und zwar
red und mich was machen wir natürlich
wir machen uns flüge auf der partie
abgesperrten und zu sagen was ich will
wissen ob es für euch auch so absurd ist
für abwegig und verrückt wie für mich
gerade ist weil ich finde dieses ganze
video ein fachbetrieb ist auch schon
lange her dass videos fast drei jahre
alt aber trotzdem wie sich das herr
warnte sicherheitsleute außen rum und
kann die moment produziert heute hinter
diesem großen lkw waren dachten wir uns
dass unsere chance den er drauf und
machen natürlich ein flieger mit der apa
red kann ich kopfrechnen und mit einem
urteil das team hier auf jeden fall sind
wir dann auch irgendwann wieder nach
hause gegangen waren kennen wir haben
glaube ich nur drei stunden gefallen
weil wir so lange wach waren und am
nächsten morgen ok stopp stopp stopp
stopp stopp stopp stopp stopp stopp
stopp stopp stopp bietet diese person
hier diese blondine da dazu gibt's auch
in der geschichte so will denn die dame
hier im bild ja es gibt nicht nur rein
zufällig daher sondern die wir auch dann
morgens irgendwann in der straßenbahn
hatte mir vom alexanderplatz wechseln in
berlin
ja die der ganze abend durch einen
einfach daraus dass brad und ich halt
weise irgendwie so ein bisschen ego sind
ja und jeder zeigen wir der größere
marke hält und wir es haben alle
möglichen scheiße zu machen zum beispiel
diese karten zu rennen oder fitness
challenge oder so und da haben wir diese
nette dame gesehen und dachte wenn du
hast erscheine bisher sagt okay wenn du
eier hat macht es die blondine an die
geschichte ja damit geendet dass ich
glaube sie beide geschlossen für diese
routine übergegangen sind iris mehr
komisch angeschaut hat wie es geht wir
sind der youtuber wissen gerade in
berlin
das war also die ganz harte haltung die
stadt gegenüber hatte ich gedacht
berichtigt um auf jeden fall aber das
war dieses video das wollte ich hab gar
keinen fall vorenthalten was einfach so
und man hat gesehen dass die seite
darüber mussten wir machen egal nachdem
ich in einer video mal gegen red
geschossen habe dann so ein video ist
einfach alles klar welches video
gefallen hat könnt ihr hier oben einen
kanal abonnieren und hier unten zufällig
andere studios hat auch hiervon auch ein
leichter und selbstverständlich wie
immer ein makel für die tatsache dass
ich gegen red in der fitness challenge
gewonnen habe